[Musica]
ma ora chiesto di fare uno scherzo di
fare 12 minuti di silenzio previsto che
questo era il momento peggiore quando si
studiava in università perché il
professore aveva appena mangiato il
primo che andava sotto francesco di
solito prendeva un bel voto il secondo
cioè io era spacciata per che comincia
la digestione era un po era un po
difficile dunque io oggi ho una missione
che lavoro faccio è una domanda retorica
è una domanda brutta di un certo punto
di vista una domanda bellissima per
altri aspetti
è una domanda che mi è stata posta nel
momento cruciale della mia vita e allora
visto che parliamo di tempo oggi su
marte il tempo di marte che è un po più
di quello terrestre abbiamo abbiamo
capito io cerco di collocare quel
momento di pando missili fece questa
domanda quando mio padre mi rivolse
questa domanda e siccome c'è sempre
nelle passioni un po di masochismo e poi
comunque sempre collegato a del sadismo
il mio padre fu veramente sadico perché
eravamo a cena con amici
io avevo finito l'università facendo gli
esami la mattina non è pomeriggio
evidentemente arrivai a un certo punto e
alla meta scena e mio padre disse
girandosi di scatto senza nessun
preavviso che lavoro fai
io ero appena diventato giornalista ci
pensai un attimo e dissi giornalista
però da lì partì tutto praticamente
tutto tutto quello che sto per dire oggi
in questi pochi minuti e che vuole
essere un suggerimento per chi per chi
lavora per i giovani che stanno per
affrontare il mondo del lavoro ma anche
per chi lo sta rimodulando usiamo delle
delle espressioni dell'esecuzioni
positive anche perché io ho iniziato
subito qui con una lamentela sono il
secondo del pomeriggio non volevo
spostare il registro mentalmente
poi deciso che quando invece ho iniziato
a lavorare non avrei più potuto
lamentarmi
elin fu sintomatica un'altra frase non
che lavoro fai ma stava andando in
un'agenzia di viaggi questa dettata
adesso è un lavoro scritto e non trovavo
il volo non trovavo il viaggio e allora
continuava a lamentarmi e la tipa
l'agenzia certo punto mi disse ma tu
devi essere più positivo con questa voce
tu devi essere più positivo ho trovato
il viaggio effettivamente c'è stato un
cambio proprio dentro di me
beh effettivamente forse bisogna cercare
di essere un po più positivo anto meno
progettuale visto che alla fine parlo
lavora nel campo del progetto in realtà
che lavoro faccio poi se fossi stato
deve riguarderebbe un po più giovane ma
ero giovane se avesse avuto un pò più di
fantasia a mio padre avrei detto ci sto
lavorando
ci sto lavorando al lavoro che faccio
perché è sempre un lavoro in
continuazione
sicuramente ho pensato e io li si sono
stato cattivo papa non vogliono glielo
detto non sono ancora riuscito a
dirglielo a vendicarmi dal certo punto
di vista ciao papà un applauso a mio
padre da che è il momento grazie anche
perché se dovesse mai vedere questo
video
ma io non c'entro niente invece centra
mood io non voglio fare il tuo lavoro
papa che hai lavorato 35 anni in
fabbrica e come mi hai detto tu hai
regalato otto ore della tua vita tutti i
giorni lavorativi al titolare della
fabbrica al brand ma soprattutto è la
seconda parte di questa frase che mi ha
colpito cioè noi
io la mamma iniziavamo a vivere dopo
dopo le 8 ore di fabbriche dove sono
stato molto fortunato perché mi hanno
permesso di studiare i miei e mi hanno
dato l'opportunità di arrivare a vivere
anche durante il lavoro poi purtroppo
questo è diventato anche una vita
nonostante lavoro con il lavoro quindi
a un certo punto poi bisogna prendere le
distanze però poi entra anche in questo
caso anche in aiuto lì per connessione
che abbiamo oggi ne possiamo uscire
decidere di lavorare in qualsiasi
istante possiamo anche decidere di non
lavorare in quell'istante lì
ripeto sono ovviamente dei lavori nostri
come della comunicazione quelli del
giornalismo
se non si lavora fissi in una redazione
sono dei lavori in un certo senso
privilegiati io io non sono un reporter
come come mou come mimosa ho lavorato
qualche volta fissa in redazione ma
soprattutto come free lance per il esca
una parola quando si va nelle fiere ci
si accredita perché testata lavoro
freelance già libro già un altro no mi
sto lamentando di nuovo
torniamo va benissimo la venissero
freelance perché lavori per più testate
puoi scrivere lo stesso articola in 17
modi diversi come succede per esempio ai
miei amici che lavorano nel campo del
design e dell'architettura
ora io ho la fortuna di lavorare in
questi due campi di fortuna perché ho la
passione degli interni dell'architettura
del progetto però anche la capacità la
volontà di farlo credo la capacità di
farlo lavorando a stretto contatto con i
progettisti i progettisti intendo gli
architetti quelli che cambiano il volto
alle città così come i designer che
cambiano la quotidianità da dove sono
partito però per appassionarmi a questa
cosa qua
fondamentalmente durante gli studi lessi
una frase del grandissimo critico d'arte
giulio carlo argan che disse l'arte del
novecento parte del secolo breve è il
design punto era scritto sulla pietra
potevo iniziare da lì ho iniziato una
tesi con enzo mari designer grandissimo
artista e teorico e da lì poi ho
iniziato a scrivere per le riviste mi
sono portata avanti ma la cosa
interessante anche in quel caso lì io
sto facendo tutt'altro in quel momento
oltre a studiare stava suonando chitarra
classica perché stavo suonando per
la la formazione da camera
dell'università statale di milano in 2d
chitarre ci pagavano in libri bellissimo
però c'è un po fatica e quindi
fondamentalmente poi ho scelto di fare
anche altro nella vita continua a
suonare però il famoso enzo mar mi disse
lei tartaro perché ci diamo sempre del
lei tartaro deve scegliere deve capire
se va avanti con la chitarra come mia
figlia che insegna in una scuola come
dire conduce una vita un po così
oppure fare altro scrivere di progetto
eccetera e da lì insomma i casi della
vita poi anno hanno portato a questo
siccome vado sempre a braccio e le prove
di ieri non corrispondono per nulla
quello che sto dicendo in questo momento
mi prendo il mio taccuino però non
essendo un nativo digitale
l'opposto lo posso fare chiedere a me
personalmente questo lo dico a me perché
mi sono chiarito le idee per preparare
questo questo breve discorso che da me
che lavoro faccio è un po come chiedermi
quale canzone dei beatles
ti piace di più ecco questa la uso
sempre della consiglio quando non sapete
rispondere per chiedermi queste come
dire qual è la canzone più bella dei
beatles dipende dalle mattine dipende da
come mi alzo dipende da come magari
prendemmo alla chitarra e faccio un
accordo oppure da come mia figlia si
mette a fare gli esercizi di prima no
che faceva luigi in qualche modo e
allora mi ricordano mi rimandano a una
canzone non si può non si può nel mio
caso scegliere di fare un lavoro e la
condizione bellissima o orrenda al
mattino che ho è quella di dire oggi che
cosa devo fare devo consegnare quello
fare quello questo lo fanno normalmente
tutti però forse lo fanno anche seduti
in un ufficio con un capo una persona di
riferimento qualcuno che può dare loro
delle indicazioni questa estrema libertà
volte mi mette in crisi perché poi
subentra anche il discorso della
vogliono ovviamente devo dire che a
livello culturale quel mio papà la che è
quello che ho
quando mi disse questa cosa mi fece
entrare direttamente nel concetto di
alienazione si portava dietro tutta una
un corpus di teorie quelle del 68 per
intenderci che che sono sintetizzate
benissimo in una frase di debord che ha
scritto tanto sono state spettacolo
eccetera e che dice lei trama ieri
sciame non lavorate mai ovviamente vuol
dire non vuol dire non fate niente
è evidente però quel ne trovai e gm in
qualche modo sicuramente è rimasto
dentro di me e forse bisogna proprio poi
buttarlo fuori no bisogna sedimentario
bisogna anche digerirlo ed evacuarlo
possibilmente senza prendere le distanze
più di tanto siccome poi ho fatto il
classico l'altra frase che mi è rimasta
impressa tantissimo una frase di flobert
che dice
in fin dei conti il lavoro è il modo
migliore per passare la vita
e allora io mi sono collocato lì nel
mezzo tra il non lavorare e questo
lavoro ideale no bene allora quale
lavoro di quale lavoro stiamo parlando
una grande società di computer che
realizza il computer ha fatto una uno
studio ha commissionato uno studio molto
importante con dati che non sto a
riportare l'unico dato fondamentale che
nel 2030 anche biraghi l'ha preso a
riferimento ormai non c'è più il 2020
siamo 2030 ovviamente nel 2030 all 85
per cento dei lavori non sono ancora
stati inventati cioè faremo dei lavori
che adesso non esistono hanno riassunto
e la cosa fa un po specie poi con una
locuzione saremo tutti dei conduttori
digitali cioè fondamentalmente dovrebbe
essere in grado di interagire con le
macchine per svolgere le nostre funzioni
quali funzioni non si sa perché sono 85
per cento non si sa che cosa sono
evidentemente siamo un po nel buio in
questo momento
cosa faccio io
ci ho pensato bene ci ha pensato bene ci
ha pensato bene e allora me lo sono
scritto io progetto come progettare il
racconto di progetto non è facilissimo a
spiegare facce dei format
fondamentalmente spiego con il video con
i testi con gli ipertesti con i social
network perché nasce un progetto di
architettura ha fatto in quel modo
perché è un oggetto di design è fatto in
quell altro modo di design non si può
dire quindi un design oggetto è fatto in
quel modo perché è uno scenario di una
azienda supertecnica lavora in
quell'ambiente si rivolge a certe quindi
una cosa non semplicissima abbastanza
specialistica però in questo ovviamente
ci sono le persone ci sono gli uomini
come oggi tutti i relatori che mi hanno
preceduto hanno fatto ben uscire questo
continuo andare rivieni in un lavoro che
non è fisso nel fatto che mi svegliano
nati non so cosa fanno sapere cosa fare
nel fatto che ogni volta mi debba
rimettere in gioco su tanti format era
per me un po una sofferenza fino a
quando fino a quando ho conosciuto nel
set
detta così sembra un po un dazio
benevolenza in realtà è così perché mi
hanno suggerito un ted di tale emily
work nick che parla del concetto della
figura dell'uomo della donna multi
potenziali chiaramente sono definizioni
di marketing anglosassone recano forse
in italia non funziona così bene però il
concetto che lei dice è fondamentale
quando ci si sente rivolgere da piccoli
la domanda che cosa vuoi fare da grande
beh lei dice io non avevo una risposta
quindi ero monca non avevo passioni non
volevo fare l'astronauta
poi ho fatto la chitarrista di successo
in una band punk ho fatto coaching fa
affatto 2000 lavori lei dice dio nordico
tutto benissimo
bene però allora mi metto dentro anch'io
in quel discorso leader del multi
potenziale
mi metto dentro discorso del multi
potenziale con l'aggravante o l'aggiunta
di del pensiero laterale del double bind
cioè scelgo di non scegliere
ho scelto il giornalismo in una chitarra
però ancora la speranza l'idea di poter
suonare qui oggi volevo iniziare con una
canzone manuel che mi ha coinvolto nel
letto ma dovrei farlo no non mi sembra
mi sembrava il caso scelgo di non
scegliere di scendono in questo caso
altro luogo e c'è sempre la metafora
sportiva dentro un discorso di questo
genere meno ce la metto che tanto fanno
poi dopo di me parlerà pessina quindi ci
sta ci sta
io ho sempre praticato di sport senza
talento però riuscendo benino in alcune
cose addirittura il pallavolo nonostante
la mia altezza un po a calcio però
fondamentalmente io ero l'universale se
si faceva male un in difesa giocava in
difesa oppure giocava in attacco non
avevo un ruolo
l'altro ieri l'allenatore di mio figlio
mi dice sai qual è il problema di tuo
figlio
dimmi che è bravo in tutti i ruoli non
riusciamo a trovargli un ruolo allora le
colpe dei padri ricadono sui figli è
evidente a questo punto però è anche
vero che è il luogo dove crescino anche
fondamentalmente gli stimoli che
arrivano a fare questo e lo io cosa
faccio mi sono scelto delle parole
chiave queste sequenze del messaggio che
mando a coloro che si devono salvare a
cena con il loro padre che spicca il
domandone ci sono tre termini che io
utilizzo sempre nel lavorare e che sono
sempre lì presenti la simbiosi a sono
mutuati dalla natura quindi ci siamo
siamo in linea nel senso che l'esempio
la natura funziona sempre no anche nate
ed esterni che abbiamo visto la simbiosi
il sintetismo è l'ultimo che un po più
bruttino il parassitismo
mi spiego brevemente
la simbiosi perché quando lavori sky fai
un progetto scrive di progetti
ovviamente devi entrare in empatia
quella persona con cui stai lavorando no
se devi fare un video di un'architettura
che sta nascendo partendo dal cantiere
arrivare all'ultimo dei dei vetri posati
in qualche modo di riuscire a cena con
l'architetto devi devi capirlo devi
intervistarlo delle vie non poco le è un
po come fare un documentario su una rock
band così ritorniamo alla musica quindi
questa simbiosi in qualche modo ci vuole
lo confermeranno gli amici giornalisti
in sala o coloro che fanno un lavoro di
questo di questo tipo
il sintetismo è molto tecnico arriva da
alvar aalto che è un grande era un
grandissimo architetto nordico il quale
diceva che l'architetto non può essere
all architetto progettista non può
essere un super specialista deve essere
una parola intraducibile dall'inglese
sinteti sta però si capisce benissimo
uno che sa fare un po di sintesi il
parassitismo invece è la parte un po più
bruttina cioè devi essere capace di
risucchiare nutrimento di trovare dagli
altri stimoli e di trasformarli magari i
nuovi i nuovi format
però bisogna stare attenti per esempio
bisogna sfuggire da quella che danno in
kruger definiscono come la dittatura
dell'incompetenza succede dicono questi
due studiosi che meno 1 st di una cosa è
più crediti saperla lunga
allora sempre mettersi in dubbio in
qualche modo c'è da dire che anche
ultimamente nel continuare a creare
format nel pensare che cosa hanno
bisogno le aziende eccetera o i
professionisti o le istituzioni all
insegnamento
io utilizzo istintivamente un metodo che
è quello del learning by doing cioè
imparare facendo che poi è un pay off di
fabbrica la scuola cucina hub di
creatività non lontanissima da qua
quindi ho un metodo assolutamente
empirico
siamo quasi arrivati alla fine vedo che
sta lampeggiando questo metodo empirico
è anche un metodo di scoperta continua
per esempio quando mi è successo quando
è bella con l'architettura non è bella
quando lavora un progetto di
comunicazione di un'architettura mi
rendo conto che lo stesso architetto
grazie al progetto di comunicazione
cambia progetto come il principio di
indeterminazione di heisenberg osservi
un fenomeno si sposta in qualche modo è
così allora cosa vuol dire che la
comunicazione il fatto di parlarne il
format in qualche modo il mio lavoro non
necessariamente io in qualche modo
intervengono a mutare addirittura il
progetto è l'architetto stesso che mette
la comunicazione e il dialogo come
strumento di progetto ora vi ho spiegato
un po che cosa potrebbe rispondere
questo ragazzo siccome potremmo anche
riassumere con consulenza quello che
riesco a fare io ho cerco di fare una
delle locuzioni bruttissime che in
passato mi infastidiva e che la
consulenza è una latitanza retribuita la
spiego meta il gira su internet non si
può essere sempre dove ti cercano dove
ti vogliono e fare quello che ti
chiedono di fare sempre bisogna essere
non furbi bisogna essere intelligenti a
gestire il tempo
ecco l'aggancio con il tempo però quello
che ho capito è che lavorando con tante
aziende amiche ci sono sempre le persone
e quello che ho capito è questa la
chiusura è che in ogni situazione anche
la persona che fa otto ore al giorno che
timbra il cartellino può essere spesso
lo è un multi potenziale quindi
fondamentalmente la mia multi
potenzialità va a convivere in simbiosi
in questo caso con chi sta dall'altra
parte che in qualche modo può essere il
mio committente potrebbe essere anche
colui che mi dice ma è da un po che non
ti fai sentire certo stavo lavorando a
un progetto comunque ha chiudo dicendo
che
c'è una frase una frase sadica crudele
bruttissima lanciato a bordo di vista ma
splendida che è sempre un mio punto di
riferimento non ce l'ho scritta nel mio
posto di studio sul tavolo da pranzo
perché il lavoro spesso da casa ma ce
l'ho proprio stampata qua è una frase di
gru ciò marx che dice non potrei mai far
parte di un club che avesse me come
membro
grazie
[Applauso]